marode schulen kaputte straßen kommunen
und länder rufen milliardensummen für
investitionen beim bunten nicht ab
präsidentenwahl in afghanistan die
beteiligung ist gering es gibt anschläge
mit toten und verletzten
park vor 30 jahren ein unvergesslicher
momente auf dem weg zur deutschen
einheit
[Applaus]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster abend willkommen zu
unserem samstags nachrichtenüberblick
mit ausführlichem sport und moderne
hallo guten abend finanzminister scholz
hat ein problem er wird sein geld nicht
los zwar stellt der bund viele
milliarden für bessere schulen
umweltschutz und digitalisierung zur
verfügung doch oft wird nur ein
bruchteil der fördergelder abgerufen
einer der gründe für scholz die
überbordende bürokratie und so
appelliert er an seine kabinettskollegen
die regeln zu entrümpeln
christoph distel geld ist da jede menge
gut 15 milliarden euro
und was man alles damit anstellen könnte
schulen sanieren straßen bauen
bezahlbare wohnungen schnelles internet
städte und kommunen die sich dabei
fördern lassen wollen müssten nur die
hand heben aber den letzten jahren
stellen wir fest dass immer weniger es
gelingt dass diese mittel auch abfließen
und das ist ein problem wenn die zeit da
ist für investitionen preisfrage also
wer ist schuld am investitionsstau wir
nicht sagen städte und kommunen er der
bund selbst mit immer mehr regeln und
auflagen es wird nicht besser sondern
schlimmer im vergaberecht beispiel
städtebauförderung gibt es sechs
programme wir haben 16 bauordnung in den
ländern die alle unterschiedlich sind
das vergaberecht ist immer weiter
verschärft worden tariftreue alles gute
ziele
die machen die sache nicht einfacher
teilweise mit vollkommen unsinnige
aufladung auch auflagen die uns dazu
führen dass wir viel länger brauchen
beim plan als unsere europäischen
nachbarn beispielsweise zu viel
bürokratie bremst eben zb beim
fördertopf für klamme kommunen satte 3,5
milliarden euro sind drin und doch
zögern viele länder sich zu bedienen vor
allem das saarland hessen und rheinland
pfalz nur rund 30 prozent des möglichen
haben die drei abgerufen und mecklenburg
vorpommern wollte sogar nur knapp acht
prozent haben bzw konnte wohl nicht
anders wer sich projekte fördern lässt
zahlt nämlich zehn prozent selbst
anders gesagt gerade für die ärmsten
kommunen ist es derzeit schlicht zu
teuer um hilfe zu rufen und deswegen
fordern viele auch der finanzminister
helft den kommunen aus der altschulden
falle damit sie endlich bauen und
investieren die fördertöpfe warten
darauf was woanders selbstverständliche
bürgerpflicht ist in afghanistan
erfordert es mut zur wahl zu gehen und
allen drohungen der taliban zum trotz
haben die afghanen heute ihren
präsidenten gewählt dabei kämpft das
land mit chaos und gewalt
noch immer sind nato truppen vor ort
auch die bundeswehr immer wieder gibt es
blutige anschläge der taliban auch heute
explosionen tote und verletzte
mehr als 70.000 soldaten und polizisten
sollten die wahl absichern
bei der zwei alte rivalen als favoriten
gelten präsident garni und sein
langjähriger gegner abdullah abdullah
knapp zehn millionen menschen waren
wahlberechtigt viele sind aber wohl zu
hause geblieben aus angst vor dem terror
kamran zafira
sie hatten glück im unglück bei einem
anschlag auf ein wahllokal in kandahar
im süden afghanistans gibt es viele
verletzte
doch dank eines massiven
sicherheitsaufgebots gibt es landesweit
bisher nur wenige opfer die taliban
hatten mit massiven anschlägen gedroht
mehrere provinzen berichten von einer
geringen wahlbeteiligung besonders von
frauen
doch es gibt ausnahmen mariam aus herat
geht erst recht zur wahl
von unserem künftigen präsidenten
erwarte ich frieden und sicherheit
und er soll sich für die rechte der
frauen stark machen präsident ashraf
ghani konnte das bisher nicht liefern
der technokrat gilt neben seinem
regierungschef und herausforderer
abdullah abdullah als favorit die bilanz
der regierung ist mäßig jeder zweite
afghane lebt unterhalb der armutsgrenze
die korruption blüht auch jetzt
berichten wahlbeobachter von
unregelmäßigkeiten
vielerorts habe es probleme mit
wählerlisten und den biometrischen
maschinen gegeben
viele afghanen wie der maurer nur
muhammad sind frustriert er hat familie
und muss sich mit gelegenheitsjobs über
wasser halten
ein präsident muss unserem land frieden
bringen er muss uns arbeit besorgen er
sollte sich mit den taliban verständigen
afghanistan muss zur ruhe kommen
die taliban aber boykottieren die wahl
sie kontrollieren mehr als die hälfte
des landes nach gescheiterten
friedensverhandlungen mit den usa über
einen truppenabzug und eine beteiligung
an der macht wird es für eine neue
regierung schwer die taliban einzubinden
erste ergebnisse der wahlen heute werden
für mitte oktober erwartet
mehr als 30 stunden war er auf der
flucht jetzt ist der mutmaßliche
frauenmörder von göttingen gefasst
polizisten überwältigten ihn vor einem
schnellrestaurant am donnerstag soll er
eine bekannte auf offener straße auf
grausame art getötet haben auch eine
frau die ihr helfen wollte ist
inzwischen an ihren verletzungen
gestorben
gegen den verdächtigen wurde haftbefehl
erlassen
heute vor 25 jahren ereignete sich das
größte schiffsunglück in der
nachkriegsgeschichte
beim untergang der ostseefähre estonia
starben 852 menschen in der estnischen
hauptstadt talinn versammelten sich
überlebende und hinterbliebene ebenso in
der schwedischen hauptstadt stockholm
die estonia war 1994 bei stürmischer see
vor der südküste finnlands gesunken
liegt bis heute auf dem meeresgrund die
meisten todesopfer wurden geborgen
noch ein jahrestag heute erinnerungen an
einen meilenstein zur überwindung der
deutschen teilung
heute vor 30 jahren sprach der damalige
außenminister hans dietrich genscher
diese berühmten worte
[Applaus]
v
der rest ging im grenzenlosen jubel von
mehr als 4000 ddr bürgern unter die auf
dem gelände der deutschen botschaft in
prag zuflucht gesucht hatten
wenige wochen später am 9 november fiel
die berliner mauer
wolf christian unrecht diese
dramatischen peter erreichten die
deutschen wohnzimmer im september 89 aus
prag ddr bürger die sich über den zaun
auf das gelände der bundesdeutschen
botschaft flüchteten mehr als 4000 von
ihnen lebten dort teils wochenlang unter
widrigsten bedingungen
peter christian bürger war damals
flüchtling und erinnert sich hier hat
man wirklich nur noch schlamm und matsch
gesehen die mitarbeiter der botschaft
hatten versucht das ein bisserl
abzumildern haben nie das gefühl gehabt
dass die menschen hier verzweifeln oder
ausgeben
heute ist er wie hunderte weitere
flüchtlinge und helfer von damals zurück
an die deutsche botschaft in prag
gekommen
zu einem fest der freiheit und um an die
dramatischen tage vor 30 jahren zu
erinnern dass wieder sieht den zaun
gesprungen ist und so ab dem 30
september 89 fuhren die flüchtlinge mit
sonderzügen richtung bundesrepublik mit
außenminister genscher war damals
kanzleramtschef rudolf seiters in prag
um die flüchtlinge über ihre ausreise zu
informieren
am bahnhof prag lieben wo die fahrt in
die freiheit begann enthüllte er heute
eine gedenktafel haben allerdings am 30
september noch nicht geahnt dass ein
jahr später die wiedervereinigung kommen
würde
an der deutschen botschaft in prag
feierten sie heute die freiheit die sie
damals in die eigene hand genommen
hatten
die barocke altstadt von dresden ist
seit heute um eine attraktion reicher im
residenzschloss von august dem starken
erstrahlen die im krieg zerstörten
repräsentationsräume erstmals wieder in
altem glanz drei jahre wurde intensiv
gewerkelt mit viel liebe zum detail ist
so ein eindrucksvolles ensemble
entstanden dass uns 300 jahre
zurückversetzt in das jahr
1719 stefan lobenstein der herrscher in
einem hermelin besetzten samtmantel mit
krone und reichsapfel
august der starke kurfürst von sachsen
und könig von polen empfehlen hier seine
gäste die jetzt sanierten neuen räume
befinden sich auf der so genannten
parade etage august hatte sie zur
hochzeit seines sohnes mit der
kaisertochter österreichs maria josepha
errichten lassen mit einer wirkung die
bis heute anhält
es ist natürlich beeindruckt weil diese
diesen weg geht
wie früher und dann sagt und hier saß
der könig es ist unglaublich ist es
wirklich wunderschön
ich bin überwältigt von der leistung
derer die das hier gemacht
300 handwerksbetriebe aus ganz europa
arbeiteten am nachbau fotos dienten als
grundlage für die beiden etwa 100
quadratmeter großen deckengemälde
kostbare seiten stoffe mit goldfäden
wurden gewebt alte technik sogar
wiederbelebt bei 100 jahre alte
webstühle die in madrid stehen die dort
diese stoffe hergestellt haben viele der
ausstellungsstücke sind originale
sie wurden im krieg 1941 ausgelagert wie
diese außergewöhnlichen gold py laster
an den wänden
das prunkstück der ausstellung ein
parade bett hier wurde nicht geschlafen
hier wurde privates besprochen oder
prunkvoll empfangen ganz wie es der
könig liebte wieder nach dresden
der sport jetzt mit leichtathletik
formel 1 fußball und rudi ja das volle
programm und gleich die ergebnisse der
fußball bundesliga und da ist der
höhenflug von rb leipzig gestoppt worden
hier sind die resultate vom sechsten
spieltag leipzig schalke eins zu drei
knapper sieg für die bayern paderborn
verliert 2 3 hoffenheim gladbach 0 zu 3
ebenso wie augsburg leverkusen 0 zu 3 1
wolfsburg 0 2 1 vfl trainer oliver
glasner ist dann gast im sportstudio am
abend ab 22 uhr darin auch das
abendspiel dortmund gegen werder bremen
union berlin frankfurt gestern 12 in der
tabelle hat bayern münchen die spitze
übernommen dahinter punktgleich leipzig
schalke gladbach leverkusen frankfurt
bleibt neunter die zweite hälfte beginnt
mit werder bremen und bis zum letzten
tabellenplatz bleibt alles beim alten
erst mal jedenfalls denn es gibt ja noch
drei spiele bis morgen erste
entscheidungen bei der leichtathletik wm
in doha die kenianerin road captain
match gewann den marathon der wegen der
hitze erst um mitternacht gestartet
wurde und zwei deutsche sprinterinnen
haben das halbfinale über 100 meter
erreicht
gina lückenkemper lieferte knappe
maßarbeit links ganz außen hatte die
em-zweite nach schwachem start mühe in
ihrem vorlauf den nötigen dritten platz
zu erreichen
mit 11,29 sekunden lag sie nur zwei
tausendstelsekunden vor der polin evers
roboter im ziel ins halbfinale am
sonntag schaffte es auch die deutsche
meisterin tatjana pinto ebenfalls als
dritte ihres vorlaufes und zwar
schneller als wirken camper ihre zeit
11,19 sekunden und diskus olympiasieger
christoph harting ist in der
qualifikation ausgeschieden
der deutsche meister martin wierig hat
sich dagegen fürs finale qualifiziert
zum vierten mal nacheinander hat der
monegasse schale klar die pole position
in der formel eins erobert in sotschi
fuhr er die bestzeit von lewis hamilton
und seinem ferrari teamkollegen
sebastian vettel vielsagende mine bei
sebastian vettel wieder geschlagen von
teamkollege schale claire und auch von
weltmeister hamilton
der ferrari das schnellste auto momentan
aber vettel bekommt seinen boliden nicht
in den griff
in seinem letzten versuch wieder ein
fehler erklärt verbessert seine eigene
bestzeit und lewis hamilton im mercedes
ist am ende 23 tausendstel schneller als
vettel
fast damit im red bull wird vierter aber
dieser dreikampf wird das rennen am
sonntag bestimmen
die niederländerin annemieke van vleuten
hat bei der rad-wm in yorkshire im
straßenrennen den wm titel der frauen
geholt
nach einer 105 kilometer langen
solofahrt sicherte sich die 36 jährige
den sieg im ziel von hellgate vor
teamkollegin und titelverteidigerin anna
fand erbringen und der australierin
amandas prex beste deutsche starterin
lisa brennauer auf platz neun und
nachher dann wieder die
leichtathletik-wm hier live im zdf dass
man sie in einen gully stürmisch wird
zuvor können sich aber manche noch über
spätsommerliche wärme freuen gleich mehr
dazu von katja hornuf so viel von uns
claus kleber erwartet sie um 21 uhr 45
zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder zur
stelle punkt 7
schönes wochenende nachts ist
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
wetter in der nacht ist zweigeteilt im
norden gibt es kräftigen regen auch
gewitter sind dabei und im süden bildet
sich zum teil nebel bei fünf grad im
süden gibt es morgen nochmal einen
sommerlichen nachschlag mit viel
sonnenschein und bis zu 25 grad
von nordwesten kommt sturmtief mortimer
heran bringt viel regen mit auch
gewitter und vor allen dingen wind
bereits am abend gibt es orkanböen im
harz und dann zieht dieses strom fällt
in der nacht auf montag von südwest nach
nordost über deutschland hinweg und auch
am montag kann es zwischen der ostsee
und dem erzgebirge noch kräftig pfeifen
voll belaubten bäumen werden da
umstürzen etwas ruhiger wird es dann am
dienstag und am mittwoch kühler
schönen abend noch